Elon Musk has filed his lawsuit against
Media Matters and he says it is
thermonuclear everybody is now joining
the war against the censorship
industrial complex that's what they're
calling it a group of activists and
political personalities who have been
filing false takedowns and waging the
cancel cancel culture war against so
many of us and now the war is on Babylon
B announced they' be pledging
$250,000 into ads on x I immediately got
on Twitter and announced we would be
joining The Babylon be's efforts with a
$250,000 ad campaign of our own and many
others also joined in Andrew Tate
pledged $1 million per month so many
people are joining the fry and Chris
pavlovski the CEO of Rumble announced
the Cavalry is coming and they too will
be assisting in the in the war against
the censorship industrial complex we
have the court filing it is it is up and
we're going to go through it and talk
about why it's so serious